Complacency. Complacency yearns for
destruction. And who better to tear down
the complacent than the
downtrodden? But the unlikely hero that
we need is the hero we cannot
find until now. Well, kind of. While it
seems like we're finally getting
dribbles of B580 stock months after its
launch, you do still kind of have to
scrge one up. But before we find out if
it's actually worth doing some scrging,
a quick word from today's video sponsor.
If every time you use your mechanical
keyboard, your co-workers and loved ones
want to batter you with it, then Be
Quiet's new light and dark mount silent
mechanical keyboards are for you. But
not only are their silent switches
silent, but they also have a dazzling
array of features from a hot swappable
numpad on the dark mount with display
keys. Very exciting. A control panel
that lets you set a bunch of features
without having to install any software
and a huge amount more. So, go check out
the be quiet light and dark mount
keyboards using the link down
below. Now, I am very excited about my
B580 GPU. I spent months ineptly looking
for one cuz I was really curious to see
how it holds up. It's a mid-rangeish
graphics card with 12 gigs of video
memory, something that's even rarer now
than it was 2 years ago for some reason.
And that video memory is important
considering that Intel targets this at
1440p gaming. Now, in terms of stock in
Canada, recently Memory Express got a
big shipment of the ASRock version of
this card, although that is at over
MSRP, which is pretty naughty and kind
of explains why they're not selling.
Now, in the US, you can also get it from
Micro Center, but they only have it as a
shippable item. At least, I think that
means it's an item that's available to
be shipped to a store, maybe. I don't
know. You can also find it on Newegg,
but the pricing is crazy. I don't know
if this is a trade kurfuffle related
issue, but that is absurd. It also seems
to be available in Europe with prices
varying in degrees of dodgy. But just
because we're seeing wisps of
availability doesn't mean you should
necessarily buy one. So, in today's
video, I'm going to compare it to the
most popular graphics card in the world
at the moment to see if you should be
interested in this ARC GPU. And in terms
of system, I'm testing it in the Geek
Squad system with an i5 14600 K and 32
gigs of RAM. A system you'd
realistically drop a B580
in. Now, we're going to start off by
getting a baseline reading. I'm using an
RTX 4060 here, which according to Steam
all of you have, and I think it'll be
really interesting to see how the B580
GPU compares to it. Now, we're currently
running Counterstrike 2 at 1080p. Now,
obviously, at 1080p, low settings, the
4060 absolutely crushes Counterstrike.
This isn't surprising at all. Uh, but I
am just using this as an example of how
esports titles run on the two GPUs. And
I think the takeaway is going to be that
it honestly doesn't matter which of the
two graphics cards you have. But I am
starting with the conclusion here. So
that's not good. Our GPU utilization
isn't super high. So our i5 is
potentially the issue here. Now power
draw is also important. We're hovering
between 80 and about 100 W. Yeah, that's
not very much for some esports titling.
I then switched over to 1440p where we
barely lost any frame rate aside from
some 1% lows. And it makes sense because
of the higher resolution, we could use
more of our GPU, giving us about the
same performance as a 1080p. Now, Doom
Eternal is another game where even at
ultra settings, 1080p, we're getting a
very high frame rate here. Uh, but the
reason that I'm testing it is cuz I'm
curious to see how the Intel GPU manages
Vulcanbased games. Uh, let's see what
happens when we jump up to 1440p. This
time jumping to 1440p does choke out our
frame rate a bit, but we're still
getting over 120 frames pers at ultra
settings. All that with relatively low
power draw. However, we are getting
close to utilizing the full 8 gigs of
video memory. But what happens when we
move to a game with some bigger teeth?
Next, I want to have a look at Cyber
Pizzle Machisle here, uh, running at
1080p medium settings. Not particularly
aggressive, but I do want headroom for
1440p to not be an unusable dumpster
fire. Uh, and it looks like we've got
quite a lot of headroom here. We've got
110ish frames pers, about 100 frames
pers in Cyberpunk does feel very good.
And our frame time graph is very steady.
It's stable. It knows what it wants from
life, and it's willing to go out and get
it. # goalboss graphics god or whatever.
Jumping up to 1440p hits our frame rate
hard, easily dipping to the low 60s,
which in direct comparison to the 1080p
result does feel a lot heavier, but it's
still a very playable experience. But
even at 1440p, our VRAM usage is pretty
low. So, we're going to have to move to
a different game to push the limits of
our 8 gigs. The Last of Us at 1080p high
settings, which I chose because the game
told me it would be fine at 1440p, uh,
which is not looking very promising at
this point considering that we're
hitting about 70 frames pers with 1080p,
which drops down to 45 frames pers at
1440p. So, this is where the graphics
cards are really starting to struggle,
but not quite as much as I imagine it's
going to struggle with our next Unreal
Engine 5 game. Now, for Stalker 2, we're
going to start off using FSR 3.1 at
native AA, which as far as I've been
able to figure out is the best way to
get Stalker 2 running at native
resolution without getting weird visual
artifacts or whatever. Now, at 1080p
medium settings, it's it's doing okay.
It's fluctuating between 50 and 60
frames per second. Uh it it doesn't feel
amazing. You can tell by our frame time
graph. We do have a little bit of
stuttering going on. Uh this is an area
where there's a lot of NPCs which does
hit the performance quite hard and this
can't help. Whatever is going on here is
definitely not helping the performance
but it's like worst case scenario,
right? Like this is um it's okay. Quick
side note, our GPU is being fully
utilized here. So no CPU bottleneck. And
again, this is in a game where you're
not going to be using native AA. You're
almost definitely going to be using uh
DLSS. And with this result, you know, we
still have reasonable input going into
our upscaling, although that starting
point does drop quite a bit lower in
1440p where we get in the mid40s in
terms of frame rate. But with that,
let's have a look at how the Intel B580
performs in rasterization workloads
before we compare their upscaling chops,
which is something game devs are
insistent we care about these days.
[Music]
So, it turns out that Intel thought not
enough people were using the screen
capture functionality in their graphics
card, so they just deleted it. It isn't
an option in it anymore. Uh, which is
really annoying because the moment that
you move the screen capture
functionality off of the system that
you're using, in my experience, the
reliability of it falls by a factor of
10. So, I'm pretty tilted now to be
honest. There's lots of lots of shouting
has happened. Uh, but we I think we're
good now. Whoa, we have way lower frame
rates happening here. For some reason,
the graphics card just feels like it
doesn't need to interact with the game
because we've just got 50% utilization
happening, which is way lower than we
got with the 4060. Uh, we are still
getting lots of frame rate, but then
when I briefly alt tabbed out of the
game, something weird happened. Wait, I
just alt tabbed out and back into the
game. And now suddenly we've got way
like double the frame rate. But it
wasn't because I alt tabbed out. The
frame rate just fluctuates wildly based
on where you're looking. Oh, it varies
so much depending on where you look.
When jumping up to 1440p, we haven't
really lost any frame rate. It It's
still behaving very similarly, but it's
still trailing massively behind the
4060, which I wasn't expecting. Yeah. I
mean, it it's so dependent on where you
look. Like, some bits give you 190
frames pers and some bits give you 400.
Now, with Doom Eternal, we're getting
100% utilization at least. Uh, now I do
kind of vaguely remember that Intel GPUs
didn't love Vulcan games, but that
doesn't seem to be the case anymore
because performance-wise, it's really
bringing the fight to the 4060 here.
Luckily with Doom Eternal, even at
1080p, we're getting 100% GPU
utilization. The same goes for 1440p. We
get a little bit of a lead here. Tiny
tiny little bit. What is cool though is
that we do have 12 gigs of video memory.
So, we have slightly more to play with.
And with Doom Eternal, we're using nine
whole extra megabytes, which just makes
me very glad we have that extra 4 gigs.
Now with Cyberpunk, I'm jumping straight
into 1440p and we're getting our first
B580 favored shellacking here at both
resolutions. And when it comes to
average and 1% lows, that's a lot
better. And that's while using about the
same amount of power. And interestingly,
it doesn't seem to be about our extra
video memory. We're just using about 6
gigs here. But it's interesting to see
how much gametogame variance there is in
the performance. The Last of Us result
was fascinating because at 1080p, the
two graphics cards basically performed
the same, but when you move up to 1440p,
the B580 steps convincingly ahead. And a
big part of it seems to be because of
the video memory, considering the video
memory utilization we're seeing here.
And you know, Intel did say that this
was a 1440p powerhouse. But with that,
let's try the destroyer of graphics
cards, Unreal Engine
5. Now, at 1080p medium settings, this
is with native uh AA, so we're running
at 1080p. We're getting about 60ish
frames pers. It seems to be very in line
with the performance we were getting
from the Nvidia GPU. It was actually a
little bit slower at 1080p, but again,
it manages to claw back some dignity at
1440p, but that's still a result which
doesn't feel great, which is kind of to
be expected of a UE5 game not using
upscaling. So, let's see how Intel's
upscaling compares to DLSS here. Oh,
that's really interesting. So, with
XESS, which is Intel's upscaling
technology, at least in Stalker. This
varies by game. Um, but here you get
much more granular settings for your
upscaling. So, you can actually start
off with
76% resolution scaling, uh, which you
can't do with DLSS. DLSS. The least
aggressive you can do is 66. Actually,
I'm going to start with ultra quality
because that's the equivalent of what I
was using in terms of DLSS. Now, when I
initially saw the XESS result, I thought
it looked a lot worse than DLSS4 because
of all of this gross smearing on the
lampost, which I didn't remember Nvidia
doing. But that artifact also exists on
the RTX 4060 when running DLSS4 at
quality settings. It just makes the
lamposts look visibly stinky. Now, in
other areas, DLSS looks a bit better,
especially when it comes to tree
smearing in the distance, but all in
all, the visual artifacts may be
slightly less pronounced with DLSS, but
it's still there. They both also really
struggle with foliage in front of a
background. I mean, this is at 1440p
quality, and I mean, those artifacts are
the kind of thing that I notice a lot.
It really bothers me. Um, but it is
different. like some people don't care
about it, but that like that is so
immersionbreaking to me. And then just a
quick final note, the B580 is also
really good value for content creation
because it natively supports hardware
acceleration for a bunch of modern media
formats which the 4060 doesn't. Although
that is offset a little bit by the fact
that Intel thought it was a good idea to
delete screen capturing functionality.
Why? Although on the note of drivers,
the Intel GPU did feel more stable than
the Nvidia graphics card cuz I did have
some weird issues with the Nvidia
drivers, which is something that's just
generally been the case for the last 5
months with Nvidia. But all in all, I
was surprised at how variable the game
performance was with the B580.
Cyberpunk, for example, saw the B580
dumpster the 4060, but with
Counterstrike, it was the other way
around. And with that, thank you for
watching. Let me know what you think of
the B580 down below. Subscribe to the
channel on the way there. And until the
next video, bye-bye.
[Music]